I may be about to die but I'm doing it
fabulous a lot of pain let's go I don't
even care about this I love it just look
at this pose right before he dies it's
awesome and do we just take a moment to
appreciate the ridiculousness of this
hey yay dad maybe the brick wall I think
that brick wall is a little bit lower so
it's gonna launch me across the bridge
oh yeah BuChE oh it's a beautiful second
let me replay because I'm never gonna
stop I have somehow managed to find the
way to perfectly dance into death taking
another one for the team oh I just look
so happy right up until now I can do
this for hours this is awesome
oh you're staring and dad has up hi
there you climb it over to the front
seat rather creepily it's so ridiculous
why wouldn't why wow I didn't even hit
the thing Oh chicken shaken
oh yeah seems totally safe Oh boss you
[ __ ] I just have to believe in myself
[Music]
disturbing yeah I'm gonna make it no I'm
not looking at me like that no no no
chicken ooh I'm a little short ass damn
I'm a little chicken shortest itty bitty
car you have to hit way to go I'm a
little chicken shoulders down here is
behind or is bound I gotta find a gap I
gotta make it through the gap
[Music]